eliezer hernandez makes his ninth start
of the season number 36 in his career
coming off a no decision against the
atlanta braves pitch now to reynolds and
it's on the way and it's down low and
it's a four pitch walk with two outs to
bryan reynolds
and uh like we said ky hernandez
features a great control
and that's back-to-back walks
and jacob stallings their catcher will
be the hitter
and oh past the second baseman chisholm
and the pirates will get a gift run out
of it comes big up back to the middle
for the space hit hopefully he'll be an
rbi right there let's see how they judge
this one they have ruled it an error on
jazz chisholm junior and what you would
talk about one [ __ ] in the armor and
it's a big one when you talk about
chisholm and the possibility of rookie
of the year 14th heir as a second
baseman
cole tucker
with a line drive base hit center field
de la cruz comes up with it again
unleashes another throw this one gets
all the way to the plate and it's
waiting for connor moran
and outfield assists for brian de la
cruz
yeah this ball's hit really good you
know again you look at the secondary
lead ball being aggressive we talked
about being aggressive early but the
secondary lead to colin moran was below
the standards that we've been used to
seeing from the base running that we've
seen lately so again he never had a
touch
so that secondary lead means everything
marlins come to bat here in the bottom
of the first inning against will crow
again having those quality starters make
a difference
oh good looking
pitch there from crow and he gets jazz
chisholm swinging and missing two up two
down see that action right there the
depth of that the change up and the way
it works away from it again finding
edges and that's what we'll crow that
one that we've seen earlier in the year
spots
and he takes ball four
well he has a handful of singles on the
season
now maybe a little bit more than that a
base it into right field sharply hit
through the right side marlon's have two
on and one out
so to go on eddie alvarez is coming up
for miami
3-1 pitch
and a ground ball through for a base hit
sanchez gets the green light here comes
the throw from right field it's cut off
and eddie alvarez has tied the game it
won
oh gets an off speed pitch out over the
plate to change up and stayed on and
kept his hands back just long enough
to get the barrel to it
and sneak it into right field
[Applause]
so effective all year long so you don't
want to allow him to beat him with one
swing in the back
and he gets a fastball he drills it
towards center field and
he will get himself a double
the way brian reynolds runs i was hoping
that ball kicked right off the top of
that wall and stayed in the ballpark
so when they make a mistake kevin that's
what happens
fastball outer plate and up
you have a guy like that all-star guy
again doing it all season long just
coming up with big hits and hard
contacts
really is on another level
diaz makes the play and finds hernandez
moving up to third is reynolds
here's the pitch the one and two
and the ball is popped up on the right
side of the infield in foul ground lewin
diaz is under it he's got it good job
pitching around that double by eleazar
hernandez
alfred though a fly ball out to left
field brinson going back near the wall
leaps and he makes the catch
a long running jumping play at the wall
for louis princeton it's hard to tell
whether or not he went over the wall but
close enough outstanding running catch
i mean that's like a wide receiver going
to the corner of the end zone right
second major league played appearance
for henry a strikeout his first time
around
henry smokes one out to center field
reynolds turns and looks and that's off
the wall
he'll get it into second base it is the
first major league hit and a double for
peyton
[Applause]
henry they'll save that one
authenticated
jazz may throw it into the netting oh
almost he got me too
now it goes through that process so that
you know it's the real deal the first
big league hit
very good balance i mentioned his first
time up you can tell that he's really
trying to stay inside the baseball and
this is uh well all the proof you need
400 feet off the wall had to really turn
it on to get into second base
diving stopped by key brian hayes
never get old seeing that that's for
sure keep brian hayes continues to show
that defense and
getting that first step quickness and
ability to move and
it's just brian b and k brian take
another look
this explosive first movement
again the footwork's always you know
again it's textbook
here's a 3-2 pitch and that's up high
ball four and it is a lead-off walk
given up by eliezer not running
and it's ball four back-to-back walks
and gets away
a gift
allowing moran to go to third and
stallings to second
with no outs
and tucker out to center field de la
cruz getting over he gets to it
and the throw will go to third sac fly
for tucker scores moran and it is a one
run game now as
tucker sac fly gives the pirates a
two-to-one lead
that's out toward right center field
long run over four reynolds dives and he
can't get there taylor cruz is on his
way to second and he's not gonna stop
gets all the way to third with a layoff
triple
we talked about all these breaking balls
well how about a nice adjustment from
dayla cruz
staying through it maybe got out in
front a couple of times early but stayed
right on it went the other way this ball
not smoked into the gap but perfectly
placed
great job wow yes
one big one
he does
wow
chris stratton
back-to-back strikeouts
did he go he did in the block by
stallings in the strikeout and raised
the jolly roger in miami
what a save
by chris stratton that was sensational